Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, I snagged a
bunch of your questions from my Telltale Games
video.
I picked a mixture of game, book and show
ones.
Generally you guys all seemed pretty pumped
about it.
Like I said once the game actually drops in
December I’ll probably use it for a weekly
giveaway on my video game channel in addition
to the book giveaway here on my main channel.
Also, I forgot to mention it, but the actor
that plays Syrio Forel was just cast in Star
Wars Episode 7.
So that’s two Game of Thrones actors, because
remember Gwendolyne Christie is also in it.
I just did a big update for it so there will
be a link in the description for that.
Syrio Forel though, probably got cast as a
Jedi, you don’t cast a water dancer if you
don’t want him to dance.
There are so many God of Death jokes you could
make in the star wars universe since Jedi
can transcend physical form.
But on to questions!
1 - Edward asks how closely will the game
be tied to season 5?
The game and the show will be separate, they
probably consulted each other a little just
to see what things the show decided to include
next year, but the game is designed so that
the story isn’t super dependent on what
goes down on the show.
They didn’t make it so you have to watch
the show to understand the game and you don’t
have to buy the game to understand the show.
The same is true for the books.
It will be a little closer to the show than
the Walking Dead game is.
But don’t expect to be hanging out with
the main characters the whole time.
And remember, decisions you make will affect
later interactions you have.
So You could turn the tide of a battle based
on which options you take.
2 - Vladimir asks will the game be free?
Only if you win one of my giveaways, seriously
though.
It’s way cheaper than a typical console
game.
In the United States for example, Destiny
on Xbox is about 60 US Dollars.
The Walking Dead Telltale Game in comparison
is only 25 US Dollars.
You can buy a season pass to get all future
episodes.
Those are the content patches where they roll
out new story.
That’s an extra $15 US Dollars.
Game Of Thrones will pretty much be the exact
same price.
I’ll be playing the Steam Version, just
because it’s more convenient, but which
ever country you live in.
How ever much the walking dead game is, that’s
how much game of thrones will cost.
They haven’t confirmed the number of episodes
per season, but I’d expect it to be on par
with Walking Dead.
There were five episodes during season 2 this
year.
3 - Space Gypsy asks are you implying you’re
Jon Snow?
I’m not sure what your talking about but
I do have the same birthday as Kit Harington.
4 - Tom Monty asks what date will Season 5
air in the UK?
Pretty much the same weekend Season 4 aired.
In the US that was April 6th, the first Sunday
in April.
So 2015 would make that April 5th.
I know international time zones make it weird,
but plan on the same premiere as last year.
They might bump it by a week.
It won’t premiere till after True Detective
Season 2 finishes it’s run.
So depending on when that premieres, it might
make them move Game of Thrones a little.
They also premiered all the big trailers for
Season 4 during True Detective Episodes.
So once that show comes back, we’ll start
getting the big season 5 trailers.
5 - Paul Long asks, do you think a spoilery
battle in the game will go down the same way
it does in the books?
I omitted the name just in case people skipped
the spoiler section in my earlier video.
Yes, the big Winds of Winter battle.
If the game goes that far it will depend entirely
on the decisions you make.
Remember it’s choose your own adventure,
so you could completely derp big battles or
make all the right choices that make you win.
Once the game gets closer to release we’ll
probably have a better idea for the narrative
arc.
I don’t think it will be exactly like the
show or the books.
I will do more preview videos for the story
when they give us more info.
6 - Matas asks Do you think Oberyn Poisoned
Tywin before his death?
No, but only because The Mountain was the
first person on his shit list.
Tywin was on his list, he just wasn’t the
first person.
Had Oberyn lived, eventually he would have
totally killed Tywin.
Presumably with his spear in the most painful
way possible.
Just run him through from the bottom end up.
7 - Joe Byrne asks do you have a favorite
book in the series and could you rank them?
It’s been a little while since I finished
book 5 but I’d say that one.
Dance with Dragons was the first book that
I anticipated, having read all the other books.
Like if you started the series when the first
book was published in 1996.
You’d get to experience that long wait and
the crazy rush when they finally release it.
I expect that when winds of winter is released,
the trend will continue and that book will
be my new favorite.
But ranking all the books so far starting
with best to less best.
I wouldn’t say any of them are bad.
But Book 5, Book 4, Book 1, Book 2 and Book
3.
Really it’s been so long since I’ve read
them that some of the events bleed together
in my brain.
Mostly right now my brain is on books 4 and
5 because of where the show is.
A lot of times I have to go back and reference
the books if I forget when something happened.
I’ll probably re-read book 4 and 5 before
next year though.
8 - Justin Wang asks could you do a Room Tour
Video?
Yes, I can’t remember which video, but I
did promise a room tour once it starts looking
like an actual place.
Right now it’s still a bunch of boxes.
I’d expect that to happen before October.
So not too long.
Definitely before I hit 500K subs.
I am planning a different special thing for
that event.
9 - Sheam cc asks, do you think Theon could
be Azor Ahai?
Right now based on the information we have
I think it’s Daenerys.
She is the closest thing to an avatar of fire.
That might change based on what happens during
Winds of Winter.
But unless things take a dramatic left turn
I already have my ideas for who the champions
of ice and fire will be.
It’s all in my White Walker Prophecy Video.
I’ll add a link to that in the description
if you want to learn more about it.
I think Theon will be important.
But mostly during the big spoiler battle in
Winds of Winter I talked about earlier today.
10 - Kevin asks is it true that the actor
playing Jaqen H’Gar is coming back to the
show?
If so will he play the Kindly Man?
Yes it is true that the actor playing Jaqen
is back, since the show is going to be different
from the books I think he could be a version
of the Kindly Man.
But if you’re a book reader and it sounds
like your are, I really think Jaqen is the
Alchemist. and the Kindly Man is someone totally
different.
The show does tend to combine book characters
a lot, so it’s possible Jaqen could become
an amalgam of a couple of the Faceless Men
characters.
For those that don’t know, the Kindly Man
is one of the Faceless Men that has an implied
leadership role in their order.
The Faceless Men are the order of assassins
Jaqen belongs to.
I already did a video explaining them so I’ll
add a link in the description for that too.
Since I originally planned to do a Faith Militant
video last week I’ll just make that my next
bonus video.
They the militarized arm of the church of
the seven and they’ll probably be featured
in Season 5.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
Congratulations to this weeks giveaway winner.
Luka Laurent, you win your choice of any of
the song of ice and fire books or the short
stories.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Next round of the giveaway starts when i post
my next bonus video.
In the meantime.
Learn more about the faceless men by clicking
here and click here to learn more about the
video game if you didn’t see that video
this morning.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!